us does anti-magic is evolving and his
new power just shocked everyone the dark
wizard King just got even stronger and
now we know why Lucius was so desperate
to keep Asta in Hino country this is it
the final epic showdown in Black Clover
begins so let's get into it you guys
already know how this works if you enjoy
my Black Clover content and you want to
see more in the future drop a quick like
and comment right now to help me out
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
watch my videos don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free but it
helps me out a lot finally this video
will of course contain Black Clover
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter we experienced that
incredible moment in which an absolutely
desperate secrete cried out for Austin
even though she thought that he was
still in Hino and then out of nowhere
Austin appeared and placed his hand on
her head to let her know that everything
is going to be okay now everything is
gonna be okay because the king is back
we waited a long time for this moment
the black Bulls sacrificed so much but
in the end they accomplished their
mission they bought enough time for
finral and the witches to bring Asta
back but we also learned that damnation
now possesses a second magic type
atmosphere magic which comes from a
supreme devil known as ball Austin
returned just in time to help the Clover
Kingdom in its greatest time of need and
socray clearly Compares him to the first
wizard King Lumiere in her mind but
before Asta can truly stake a claim for
becoming the new Wizard King he has to
actually take down damnatio and then he
has to take the fight directly to Lucius
good intentions alone are not enough to
become wizard King Asta has to prove
himself both capable and willing to act
decisively and for firmly when the need
arises and there has never been a bigger
need for such a decisive action than
right now the latest chapter starts off
a little bit further back in time in
order to give us the full story of how
Asta made it from Hino to the fight with
damnatio that's how Shonen manga often
Works they give us an epic high
intensity moment and then they rewind it
back a bit just to give us more context
and let's be honest to tease us a little
bit before the action resumes thankfully
you don't have to worry about this
chapter ending before something new and
intense happens because Asta vs dematio
does indeed get going Asta showcases a
new amazing power and he tears into the
Amnesia without Mercy or hesitation
stick around until the end of the video
because we will talk about all of it it
was amazing but first things first back
in Hino Ryu gives Asta a heads up that
his allies are coming for him and that
he needs to get ready yosuga and ichika
are also there along with Austin Ryu and
and Austin thanks them all for
everything they've done they helped
train and prepare him for the upcoming
battle and they allowed him to attain
new levels of power and to learn new
useful techniques that he never would
have learned if he hadn't been
transported to Hino then suddenly the
portal appears and finral and Rouge
emerged from inside finral holds out his
hand to Asta and Asta is delighted to
see his black bull Senpai ryuthen asks
fineral if he has room for one more
inside the portal because the girl who
is there with them ichika is going to
join them in the fight to protect the
Clover Kingdom Ryu explains that she is
one of the strongest and most skillful
fighters in Hino country so she will
certainly be a great help to them in
their battle against Lucius however it
doesn't seem like Ryu cleared this with
ichika first because she clearly doesn't
want to leave ryu's side nevertheless
each guy is told that if they can't
defeat Lucius back in the Clover Kingdom
then the land of sun will be finished as
well in order to protect Ryu and Hino
which is her first priority ichika has
to make sure that the good guys win in
the war back in the Clover Kingdom
yosugai assures ichika that he will
protect Ryu and the land of the Sun in
her place because after all asta's thing
ended up working out best with her and I
know what you're thinking oh what does
he mean by asta's thing I know what
you're thinking but I'm not gonna say it
because I don't want to get demonetized
I'm sure he's talking about zetting or
something along those lines okay guys
chill Ryu then instructs ichika to go
and see Ami and to make sure that she
comes back alive ichika is still
hesitant but she won't disobey her Lord
and I'm sure that she also knows that
they all have a point if Lucius wins the
war then all the distance in the world
won't be enough to protect Hino country
from his Godlike power they have to stop
him not only for the sake of the Clover
Kingdom but for the sake of the entire
world Ryu and yosuga then encourage Asta
to go out there and beat Lucius and he
vows to do eggs exactly that also liebe
is there in his chibi form just look at
all cute and chilling on Austin's
shoulder it's easy to overlook him
because he's so small and quiet but he
is indeed there we are then taken all
the way back to the present moment Asta
emerged out of the portal first and he
is already on his way to confront
damnatio after briefly comforting sacrae
as we saw in the last chapter fineral
and ichika also emerged from the portal
behind Asta but Asta doesn't turn around
to look for them his attention is
focused on all of his black bull
comrades who are lying unconscious and
bloody all over the battlefield actually
the witch Queen and all the witches are
laid out and unconscious too even though
he didn't actually see them fighting so
their injuries kind of happened
off-screen finral who hasn't seen the
full extent of the Carnage yet is also
shocked by what happened and Asta has a
very grave and dark expression on his
face the time for smiling and friendly
reunions is over it's time to make
damnation pay for what he's done on
damnation marks are stars saying that
yes he arrived now but he came only
after all the black Bulls had already
fallen they've all been severely injured
because Asta couldn't make it back
sooner and it's clear that Amnesia is
trying to provoke Costa he wants also to
get mad to lose his composure and to
make wild and Hasty moves that the
Amnesia will be able to exploit but
Austin knows better than to allow the
Amnesia to manipulate him he raises his
left hand and summons the demon
Destroyer sword and we see all that Wild
dark anti-magic energy that looks like
tendrils seeping out of the sword Asta
says that maybe just maybe everyone can
still survive but he will need finral's
help finral has to focus on treating all
the injured and ensuring that they don't
die from their injuries while he does
that Asta vows to take care of
themnation on his own finra and sakrei
are shocked to hear this but Austin is
determined to solo the nation and he
declares that he is not going to lose
again the Amnesia knows that his scale
magic is meaningless against someone who
has no magic in the first place but he
believes that Ball's atmosphere magic
will still allow him to pass judgment on
Asta but unfortunately for damatio it is
in this moment that Aston wails his
brand new power Asta says domain
expansion and suddenly damnatio is
trapped within Austin's domain black
hole oh wait that's the wrong manga I
started making some Jujutsu Kaizen
content on the channel recently so
you'll have to forgive me but Asta does
do something incredible as he walks the
anti-magic tendrils that emerge from his
demon destroy his sword begin to form a
protective barrier around him and this
anti-magic barrier is able to negate
even the atmosphere magic of ball who as
we know is a supreme rank devil damnatio
is stunned and he quickly realizes that
asta's magic is evolving or I guess he
means that his anti-magic is evolving
finwell notices that ostas now even more
capable of controlling anti-magic and
his control is now more precise and more
effective than ever before then the
issue understands that anti-magic poses
a great disadvantage to him but he
believes that with his sword he can
still win with the help of The Sword and
the blessing of Lucia Sama he will slay
The Sinner Asta in the name of justice
but Asta isn't playing around anymore
with an intense expression Austin looks
square at amnesio and asks him what part
of his actions align with peace or
justice as he says this Asta summons the
demon slasher Katana in his other hand
and cuts right through damnation using
the power of zetan d'amnacio doesn't
even have time to react and I don't
think he even had a chance to use his
sword to defend himself Austin's attack
was just that fast and that merciless we
gotta remember that zetan is a technique
that damnatio wouldn't be familiar with
so he probably wasn't expecting Aster's
attack to be as strong and as fast as
was and on that absolutely epic note
this chapter comes to an end whoa this
was exactly what we needed to see from
Asta no talk no Jutsu no messing around
no mercy damnatio messed with us as
friends and he had to pay for what he's
done now am I saying that Amnesia is
dead after this attack no I am not even
though this would be a fatal wound under
normal circumstances there is Magic and
anti-magic involved here and in general
I never assume anyone is dead in Black
Clover unless we have clear and absolute
proof for all we know Asta might have
just purified diametio like he did with
sister Lily but whatever happens to the
Amnesia now I'm extremely interested in
the evolution of Austin's anti-magic and
where his new power is going to lead him
is this the birth of the long-awaited
anti-monozone the anti-magic equivalent
of monozone we've been speculating about
the possibility of hostile developing
anti-monozone for a very long time and
it seems that he is almost there a
protective barrier that surrounds Asta
and negates all the Spells and their
effects in the surrounding area is
sounding a lot like the anti-magic
version of monazon and with all the
different magic types that Lucius
possesses and with the insane amount of
Mana that he possesses anti-monozone may
be the only way for astha to actually
defeat him what do you guys think is
this the birth of anti-monazone and what
kind of additional power-ups are you
expecting Asta to get before the end of
the story it's clear that his powers are
evolving and becoming both stronger and
more precise but what else can we expect
could he attain a brand new form to go
along with his Superior control and
power could the very nature of his
anti-magic change into something greater
like black hole magic will he learn to
create an unlimited void of anti-magic
oh and why is ichika here what role do
you expect she will play in the battle
and are you as excited as I am for her
reunion with Yami don't forget to share
your feedback down in the comments if
you enjoyed this black color video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and if you're one of the
over 50 of people who watch my videos
but haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a huge favor and make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it helps me out a
lot with the channel